my advice to democratic legislators
is get addicted to victory you know that
feeling you had
that when you were like we're helping
hundreds of millions of people
everyone's going to love us people are
going to get those 1400
checks people are going to get this
child tax credit like we're going to be
heroes
just get addicted to that just be like
that is not enough
yeah i i read a newsletter once a week
and uh
this was writing about this exact topic
and i
i compared the advice i had for them to
the advice that you get from like
the worst baseball coach in little
league who like watches
you hit a home run and it's just like do
that again do that again like do that
again
that is useless in baseball but i think
i
i think you know legislating is actually
a very complicated thing but
given the limitations that democrats
have they have 50 votes everyone needs
to be on board so everyone's potentially
a king maker
anyone could spoil this thing so
basically everyone has to agree not to
do that
once you get that kind of consensus that
we have to just move
uh then i think it's possible and it's
not a model of legislating that i think
you'll see repeated a lot in history if
they do it but i think it's you know
it is possible because what you say like
the the rescue plan was a huge win
uh they feel good about it so why not
repeat the process
[Music]
all right welcome back to yang speaks on
today's episode we've got the
editor-in-chief
of crooked media brian boitler joins
for a conversation with andrew they talk
politics on a national scale which we
haven't done in a while
brian is actually doing a ton of
coverage on
the first 100 days of the biden
administration so it's a fascinating
conversation between
brian and andrew you're going to enjoy
it tune in now
[Music]
[Applause]
it is a pleasure to welcome to the
podcast
the editor-in-chief of crooked media and
the host of the new podcast rubicon
about the first hundred days of the
biden administration which are passing
very quick you might need to do the
second hundred days in just a minute
brian boitler welcome brian thanks for
having me
uh you know there are a lot of reasons i
like you uh but one reason i like you is
that you have i think a physics and
astronomy degree from uc berkeley which
strikes me as such like unusual
background for like a political voice
uh and and also my dad has a physics
degree from berkeley so
that's one reason i like you i think it
was helpful
to like i moved to washington to do
journalism
kind of from the the hometown i grew up
in which was in the middle of nowhere in
california
and so i didn't i worried that i
wouldn't have any way to distinguish
myself
i didn't have any like networks to tap
into to break into journalism which a
lot of young journalists do have
but the fact that i was coming from a
physics and astronomy
background actually worked to my
advantage because most of the
young journalists trying to break in
were poli sci majors or whatever
and uh and so it was a rarity and that
and that helped but the
the problem is that it it stuck and i've
been doing it for
16 years now and i've forgotten almost
everything i learned in college oh don't
worry about it man
you know i'm sure that physics would
come back to you if you were stuck on a
desert island and that
you know like make something happen um
so you grew up in
in a small town in california and when
you showed up to berkeley it must have
been a bit of an
adjustment and i say this because my
parents met at berkeley
my brother is named after the lawrence
observatory
and then he went to berkeley and then i
spent some time at berkeley with him
uh it's a it's an incredible environment
it's got a reputation as a real
hotbed of political activism uh did it
activate you in some way or were you
activated before you got there
looking back there definitely was some
element of culture shock coming from
the inland empire redlands california to
berkeley
but part of what made it an easier
adjustment
is that the bay area in general and
berkeley and
in particular have this reputation
everywhere but particularly in
california
of being just completely off the wall
crazy right
and so when you actually get there
and it's a little weird here and there
like different in
in some ways but not so much different
than regular life
uh it i i feel like the the outsized
expectations for how
out there the place is made it easier
for me to adjust disappointing
you're like just college kids doing
normal college good stuff
um but there was you know in redlands
there was no radical politics there's an
awful lot of radical politics
in berkeley um and i was there when 9 11
happened i was a sophomore
um and then so obviously i was still
there when the war in afghanistan
started and the war in iraq started and
berkeley was a hub for a lot of anti-war
activity
um and you know i'm not sure what kind
of
person or intellect i'd be today if i
hadn't been
in the bay area at berkeley for that
formative experience because it was a
moment where i feel like the culture and
politics
were pulling people in one direction or
another to be skeptical of what the
government was doing or to just be
extremely jingoistic about it and so i
think i i
uh it it pulled me in what i
in retrospect think of was the right
direction well i
i mean i agree with the direction it it
pulled you in that's for sure
you went to dc you reported for a bunch
of different publications that were kind
of in the orbit
of crooked media before they managed to
wrangle you
is that about right that's right and
i've been to the qriket media studios uh
in la i've interacted with a lot of your
colleagues i i
i love crooked media you all are like
the next generation voice of politics
so many people get their information
from you i feel like you're
edifying uh the next generation uh
and really shaping the political culture
in a profound way so
to the extent that they did get you i
mean i i feel like it's it's an
incredible org and i feel like being
editor-in-chief is probably a massive
responsibility no
no pressure anything brian well
i mean a lot of the a lot of the uh
shows we produce don't really benefit
from my
midas touch or anything like that but
you know it's no it's not a coincidence
that after
after getting my first internship and
then my first job i didn't
at any point move into a big media
company
i've always worked at smaller
independent media companies and i
anticipate that i'll continue to do that
uh for the reasons you say it's
it's easier to innovate it's also i
think in a lot of ways easier to be
honest about
what you're seeing in the world and
there's a bit of a disconnect i think in
journalism like a lot of people
not in all of journalism but in
political journalism specifically
where the you know the um ideal the bo
ideol of journalism is that you
see what's happening and you tell your
readers or whoever the
the truth about what you're seeing and
in political journalism there's so many
compromises you have to make
to operate within the system that
particularly at big media companies you
aren't always conveying to your audience
exactly what it is you know
wow wait this is so deep tell us more
brian tell us
[Laughter]
it's hard it's it's very hard it's easy
to generalize it's much
i think better to talk about specific
things and maybe we can get into it with
respect to biden but
you know the the you you'll hear these
terms if you
if you dwell in the in the world of
media criticism a lot you know both
sides or he said she said
uh those are artifacts of having to
retain sources and access to
both political parties and uh
when the you know when the relationship
is built on those terms
uh it's very hard to break out of that
box and say when the
two parties have gone in very different
directions right um
and so i feel like that basic dynamic uh
infects a lot of
marquee journalism and i don't think i
would succeed in that
environment and so i've sort of steered
clear from it wow
i love it uh you know that that i mean
that that simple commentary explains a
lot of people's frustrations frankly
with like a lot of political journalism
and i do genuinely think that crooked
media does a better job
of having a point of view and just
calling it like you see it
in part probably because you're a little
bit less entrenched you know what i mean
like i think people kind of expect you
all to have
uh individual voices and points of view
uh and i think that's why people love
you honestly i think that's why people
are attracted
um to your materials you know i think if
if the if the company or people at the
company ever decided they wanted to turn
it into something more like fox news
where it was just propaganda for
democrats it would not be a fun place to
work but the what
i think what cements the bond with the
audience and what makes it a good place
to work
are that you know i there's no
uh doubt i think in anyone's mind who
listens
which party the the host of pods of
america think is the better of the two
parties
which you know what views they think are
the uh
you know better views but like there's
no
hiding or erasing bad news stories for
democrats
and there's no making up lies about uh
republicans or conservatives so there's
a slant
but it's it's true and people who listen
to it will be better informed
whereas i think ideological media on the
right
is not does not work that way it's not
constrained by reality
right and so and so and so people who
are immersed who only get their news
from say fox news or even now newsmax or
oann they come away
believing things that are false uh and
that's just not gonna happen to people
who listen to
our shows or read our website or
subscribe to our newsletters or anything
like that
i finally started going to the gym again
feeling pretty good about it and
i just went and i used my new pair of
raycon wireless earbuds
when i went and they were awesome it's
like they're built for me to move around
in which is cool
there's no wires or stems or things like
that to get in your way they come in a
range of different colors
mine's blue which is awesome and they're
built to perform anywhere at any time so
they're water and sweat resistant which
i liked and the bluetooth
pairs super quickly with my phone so
whether you're listening to a podcast
like this one or binging an audiobook or
going through a workout like i'm talking
about raycom is awesome their battery
life's up to six hours
and frankly it's accessible like the
wireless earbuds are starting at half
the price of other premium audio brands
which is cool so right now raycon is
offering 15
off all their products for our listeners
and here's what you got to do to get it
go to buy raycon dot com slash yang
that's it you'll get 15 off your entire
raycon order
so feel free to grab a pair and a spare
that's fifteen percent off by buy
raycon r-a-y-c-o-n dot com slash yang
byraycon.com
yang check him out
[Applause]
so you just said hey people know that if
we
uh have a choice between these two
parties we're much more
uh in line with the democratic party and
the republican party which i happen to
be as well
and i think a lot of people agree with
that um but there are some folks who get
frustrated with the democratic party
from time to time and i
i had a conversation with one
one person who i'm just going to throw
out there because she came to my head
was brianna joy gray who
said like hey the democratic party you
know like kind of frustrating sometimes
um but we we are in such this
bifurcated two-party system uh and
the last number of years we've just been
trying to get trump out and trying to
you know like keep things together
um so is there a point of view either
either of you individually or the folks
you work with around
the problem of polarization that ezra
kline and others have written about
the two-party system like whether
there's a need to evolve
which is one of the things that brianna
was arguing for and brianna's arguing
for it from one point of view there are
disaffected republicans or arguing from
another point of view they're like other
people that have
so like do you either individually or
institutionally have any point of view
on whether this two-party system is
working
so i i think it's sort of built into the
dna of the country at this point which
is
the source of a lot of frustration for
progressives people further to the left
i think that
the democratic party is like
the like left-wing coalition
you would see in a parliamentary system
except instead of it being a
coalition of multiple parties it's one
party and everyone has to kind of make
it work
you know whichever faction is
disempowered and for years that's been
the left
uh it does feel like we need a third
party because
our views are just not really even on
the table when it comes time to govern
um i think that's less true under biden
than it was under obama and it's
you know moving in a more genial
direction the the polarization question
i kind of view a little differently
when i hear polarization i think
you have two parties they once upon a
time were similar and then they kind of
moved away from each other and for
someone who wants to dig into that
history
uh ezra klein's book why we're polarized
talks about just how similar the two
parties were
a number of decades ago and then they
they like which is
um something that i frankly did not
realize until i read that book
um that because you think about
democrats and republicans are standing
for different things
and there was a period when they were
really very very similar
you know my my grandfather was like an
eisenhower republican but by the time
he died he was like an obama democrat
and really that's just the same thing
i think that that kind of illustrates
the point you're making in the yeah yeah
totally
in the person of my grandfather but
that's what i think of when somebody
says polarization
the two parties moved away from each
other and i think that's very imprecise
and a lot of i think
experts political scientists agree and
they coined a new term
asymmetric polarization to convey the
fact that the republicans have raced
right much faster than the democrats
have raced left i still find that a
fairly unsatisfying description
of what happened in american politics
because it it never that like it
nevertheless suggests that at some
dna like level the two parties share
certain precepts about how you
how you govern a country like what what
the country even means
and i think at some point along the way
past the the gingrich era
the republican party kind of speciated
into something else where
uh they didn't have like a a liberal
right-wing fringe
that existed in coalition with uh
small l liberals who just wanted lower
taxes more markets etc
they have given you like yielded to the
illiberal right wing and so now you have
a party
that rejects uh fundamental precepts of
self-governance
you're right that polarized is an
oversimplification kind of both
sides-ism in itself
and what happened to the republican
party is just like a very different
thing
and i i totally agree with you and i
think that what happens is that as it
as it becomes the hub for people voters
elites who
um don't really believe in democratic
elections
um who don't believe in sort of like
generally applicable neutrally
applicable law you know the law should
be our friend and
uh and that you know like a tool to
punish our enemies
that you you get some sluffage of the
of the remnant you know ant we call
anti-trump republicans or never trump
republicans
and some of them join the democratic
party and it makes the democratic
coalition
ever more unwieldy but i but i think it
also
i think it also probably slows the
democratic party's
creep to the left in that it has to be
the party that contains
the small d democrats of society so
that's why it contains bernie sanders
and joe manchin and the never trumpers
and somehow it has to work um the
it's hard for a party that constituted
in that way
to really dart in one ideological
direction or another
wow i i loved that uh explanation brian
talking to you is a lot of fun
appreciate it now i suppose we're going
to get into the meat of this thing which
is how's the bind administration going
i know you unpack this on the podcast
which we recommend rubicon about the
first hundred days
of the biden administration so you've
been watching this more closely than
just about anyone
i have been pleased with the biden
administration from my vantage point
i thought that the american uh rescue
act
or plan act i guess it was a plan and
then became an act
yeah arpa america rescue plan act
oh thank you perfect distinguishing uh
i loved it you know i'm part of the i
think you know 72 percent of americans
or so who who loved it
uh i love that they're trying to define
infrastructure broadly
do a lot of big things uh the fact that
it was
uh so narrowly won uh i think zero
republicans certainly zero republicans
in the senate voted for it i think maybe
zero in the house as well
and that uh the uh american rescue plan
act
uh needed kamala to come and
be the deciding vote and then they
looked up and said wow we just passed a
1.9 trillion dollar act uh with not a
single republican vote like what else
can we do
looking around being like oh like this
infrastructure plan could look really
good
but then it goes to a then it goes to
what you just described which is that
democrats have a lot of different people
a lot of different uh perspectives and
now you can't lose a single vote so
you're looking around saying like
can we get this done uh is it was is
that an app description
i think so i think i agree with
basically everything you said you know
when we were planning the show
uh we didn't know if democrats were
going to control congress if they were
going to have the senate thank you again
georgia thank you georgia
thank you reverend warnock john ossoff
all right continue
the difference between a first hundred
days show where congress is divided
and a first hundred days show where
democrats have unified control of
government uh
is night and day there'd be more
dramatic tension in the show
if democrats hadn't won the senate
which is not to say it's oh my gosh i
occasionally so i spent
weeks campaigning in georgia and the
picture i painted all the time
brian was do we really want senate
majority leader chuck schumer
just aiming the car at a ditch like
for another four years like do you
really all think that's gonna be a good
move and
you know anyone who talks about
bipartisanship it's like it really just
boils down to mitch mcconnell
yeah driving driving the car into a
ditch so i completely agree with you
that
if you were to plan this first hundred
days of the blind administration it
would have been incredibly fraught
and dramatically mitch had to say yes to
things
well if if you think he would have had
to say yes to things
the way we were kind of anticipating
things if georgia went sideways
was you know maybe democrats would get
one more
small coveted relief bill it wouldn't be
uh big enough to you know do
uh what i think needs to be done to fix
the country but it would help
and that would be sort of the end of
legislating
uh at least big deal legislating biden
would probably have to be more
aggressive with his executive power
um democrats in congress probably would
have
felt more pressure to do uh more in the
realm of trump accountability use their
subpoena power to
finally get some answers to the
questions that he stonewalled them on
for the
for the last four years um and we would
have had to evaluate
biden's first hundred days on a whole
different set of terms
and it would have been harder for him to
lay the groundwork for a successful
presidency in an environment
where he was unable to pass a bill large
enough to hopefully get the economy
stabilized
when they won georgia it it changed and
so
suddenly his potential you know for
greatness or whatever you want to call
it
rose um and which meant in some ways the
stakes were higher like
we would have all noticed if the
american rescue plan had failed or if he
had to dramatically cut it down
to get 50 votes for it um and one of the
i think a
fair metric for success is that he
introduced this 1.9 trillion
plan uh and it passed almost completely
unchanged from how he
asked congress to pass it um and
uh and you know now unlike in 2009 where
you had a lot of economist warning
this stimulus bill isn't going to be big
enough for how big a hole we need to
fill
now it's you know almost universal this
is the right size bill
and maybe you have like some dissenters
saying it might even be a little too big
and we might have to contend with some
inflation like that's a night and day
difference between how the last
democratic trifecta dealt with a crisis
and how this one did i
i think it's the right size seems right
but as a matter of fact when i drew it
up i said joe 1.9 trillion would be
just about right
so have you ever browsed an incognito
mode i used to use it when i was buying
flights
trying to make sure they weren't jacking
up the price as i kept looking at
something but it is not as incognito
as you think incognito does not mean
invisible and a lot of these browsers
have a form of like privacy mode
and they don't really work that well so
how do you actually make yourself
invisible
express vpn so it turns out that even in
incognito mode your online activity
still gets tracked and data brokers can
still buy and sell your data data
harvesters use your ip to uniquely
identify you and your location but with
expressvpn
your connection gets rerouted through an
encrypted server and your ip address is
mass so every time you connect
expressvpn you get a random ip address
it's custom to you it's only shared
within the expressvpn customer network
it makes it harder for third parties to
identify and harvest your data
and best of all it's super easy to use
even i can use
it and i'm kind of tech illiterate at
times so here's the if you really want
to go incognito and protect your privacy
secure yourself with a number one rated
vpn visit expressvpn.com
yang and get three extra months for free
that's e-x-p-r-e
dot com slash yang expressvpn.com
i ran into chuck schumer today um in
brooklyn
and he had on a mask that said cancel
student debt
which i appreciated a great deal from
the majority leader
i know there's been some discussion as
to whether joe has the ability to cancel
student debt
via executive order and then some people
have gone back and forth i'm going to go
on the record and say if i were
president i would certainly be testing
my ability to do that
it's like let's see if we can do it do
you have a point of view both on
uh the ability to cancel student debt
and then the wisdom of doing so it's
it's hard to say like i
i i listen to lawyers who
know this area of the law really well
and they make very persuasive
arguments and in a world where i thought
the way things worked was that if you
had sound legal arguments for something
you got to do it
um you know i'd say yes he absolutely
can do it and it's just a matter of
making sure that he follows the
administrative procedures act or
whatever he has to do to uh to make it
lawful
uh when when done but in the world we
actually live in the question of whether
he can do it or not is going to be
answered
perhaps by uh a very skewed
supreme court and i have no idea what
they're going to say
um oh no oh no this new supreme court
because the court is not like a natural
ally of the biden administration
uh what do you do about that well one
argument is you got to move fast because
you're very likely to run into legal
issues with
the supreme court and have to take a
second bite at things or whatever
uh the the flip side of that is that if
you move too fast and you don't
dot all your eyes and cross your t's
then the work you do might end up
getting thrown out on some sort of legal
technicality as opposed to the the
substance of the law
so i think that that probably explains
part of why
um you know we're gonna probably cross
the 100-day threshold and
and he won't have uh forgiven any
student debt
um but uh there are other considerations
too
um i think that you know in an
environment where you've
just passed a two trillion dollar
coronavirus relief bill
and you want to pass another very large
bill that won't be fully
financed um if you're going to
play ftse with with inflation maybe you
want to
see what happens with those before you
write off another several hundred
billion dollars
in student debt um and that may be part
of the reason why they're not
racing to do this i think there's a
there's a there's a third
uh issue to consider which is if you're
gonna do something like that which pulls
pretty well
will definitely make a lot of your own
voters enthusiastic likely to
show up at the polls do you maybe want
to try to do it closer to an election
um i think that all of those uh factors
are probably
contributing to uh the internal debate
uh uh at the in the biden administration
over what to do
when to do it how big to go that's
fascinating you're right that it would
be hundreds of billions of dollars if it
was going to be significant at all i
think the level of
education uh debt out there right now is
1.6
trillion last night i'm operating from
memory here but i think that you know
the
the smaller relief uh idea that that
biden has embraced at ten thousand
dollars
worth of student debt and and uh phase
out um
is somewhere in the 300 billion dollar
range and the
and the schumer uh warren plan the uh
sort of fifty thousand dollars just
forgive as much debt as you can is about
a trillion
so it's a lot of money um it's not if he
it
it would have been a no-brainer i think
in an environment where mitch mcconnell
was running the senate and had said no
to the american rescue plan
well then you need to get money out the
door and that's a that's a freebie um
just do it
some students right now are wincing at
this
i know well that's the thing is that for
all for all these uh
any kind of stimulus like the nice thing
about the rescue plan is that it was
very broad-based like it's a few people
relatively speaking myself yourself
perhaps you got like no have gotten no
covet relief over the last
year uh we're like in the small minority
of people who
don't qualify and basically everyone
else gets a stimulus check many people
get
get unemployment et cetera et cetera the
student loan
uh plan is comparably much more targeted
and so when when you stop talking about
aggregates
huge sums of money being distributed
broadly and start talking about
individual programs and you say well
because we did this one thing now maybe
we have to take a pause on the other
thing
well then the constituency that would
benefit from that is like well i was
told that i was going to get my student
loan forgive when when's that gonna
happen but you know
a promise is a promise i expect it's
coming i don't think he's going to
renege
well that that's great news uh to a lot
of people
and one of the things i did suggest
which the american rescue plan act does
address in
in large part is that you want to get
money out very broadly like you don't
want to pick a certain segment of the
population
and say we're going to help you and not
necessarily get help to others
[Music]
[Applause]
all right let's face it guys taking
trips to the post office is probably not
how you want to spend your time and
that's why we recommend
mailing and shipping online at
stamps.com stamps.com allows you to mail
and ship anytime
anywhere right from your computer send
letters ship packages
and pay a lot less with discounted rates
from usps ups
and more and stamps.com has saved
businesses thousands of hours
and tons of money so with stamps.com you
get the services of the post office and
ups
all in one place i love it because i
always forget to either buy stamps or
don't even think about it and i'm like
oh crap what do i do go to stamps.com
bang it's right there super simple easy
you can do it from anywhere you are
because we travel a lot
ship stuff extremely conveniently so
here's the deal stop wasting time going
to the post office and go to stamps.com
instead there's no risk
and with our promo code yang you get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long term commitments or contracts so
just go
to stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the home page
and type in yang that's stamps.com promo
code yang
stamps.com never go to the post office
again
[Applause]
[Music]
so what is your prognosis for the
infrastructure bill what are we looking
at
uh brian you know because there's so
many people that want a lot of things in
there and let me also say on the record
i love it all like just about everything
i've seen i'm like sure throw it in
there
[Laughter]
so what what are you seeing and hearing
in terms of
um it could be at this point individual
legislators and like their pet issues
like what they will and won't accept
uh the ultimate size of the bill i've
seen something in like the
two trillion dollar range i i believe
uh is this also going to be a bill that
gets no republicans i get the sense that
it probably will be from
[Music]
what i'm hearing look in a world
where uh the filibuster were to be
abolished or reformed if
democrats were to do that before
reaching
uh the jobs plan you could you could
imagine a world where you you break that
bill up into different
pieces and some republicans maybe a
handful of them support this piece but
not that piece but mostly democrats pass
the whole thing in piecemeal but because
the rules of the senate are what they
are and it seems like question whether
they're going to abolish or reform the
filibusters now kind of in doubt
you have to do it as one giant package
and put it through the budget process
so that you can circumvent the
filibuster so that makes it hard you
have to hold
all 50 senators together all like make
sure that
nobody's uh like ideas that they care
deeply about are
omitted also not at ideas that are
viewed as sort of poison pills to
uh you know joe manchin on the one end
or bernie sanders on the other
um you have to uh find a method of
paying for it that isn't pa you know
raising taxes too aggressively or
or two or not paying for enough of it
and not because
there's necessarily a right answer that
question but because you need all 50
uh members to agree and that's a hard
thing to do part of me thinks it's sort
of like
too big to fail in some sense like i
don't think democrats want to go
into the midterms having dealt joe biden
a very big defeat
because he's basically said this is what
we need to do and
like he's put his whole administration
behind it and
um you know that gives me uh like some
hope that
that it'll pass but for that to happen i
think
democrats have to embrace
that feeling this the sort of psychology
that they had
after the rescue plan passed right where
they didn't let
their uh peccadillos uh eat away at the
bill until it
fell apart or got you know became too
small there wasn't a lot of rancor that
bill passed and everyone was happy and
everyone thought they did a good thing
and everyone felt proud that they can
kind of repeat that process
where they say you know there will be a
time to fight for my pet project
on future bills but for this bill what
we need to do
is limit the amount of rancor in within
our own ranks
um and we also uh we also need to move
quickly
and uh and we we need to you know
satisfy ourselves with
very small trims around the edges as
opposed to big changes
then they can just do it and it'll pass
they'll feel good about it again
and then they can resume squabbling over
you know the more trivial issues that
divide
them um the risk is that you know
there's no
there's no deadline to pass this bill
there's no this this bill will
seemingly have a tax component so it's
just harder
to get that kind of agreement to get
people to agree to set aside their
uh their priorities and just trust that
joe biden's plan is the is the right
plan
um and i think it sort of remains to be
seen whether they can do that it'll be a
big feat if they do and
uh it'll be a big legacy uh piece for
biden but also for chuck schumer in a
way
my advice to democratic legislators is
get addicted to victory you know that
feeling you had
that when you were like we're helping
hundreds of millions of people
everyone's gonna love
us people are gonna get those 1400
checks people are gonna get this
child tax credit like we're gonna be
heroes just
get addicted to that just be like that
is not enough yeah i i write a
newsletter once a week and uh
this was writing about this exact topic
and i
i compared the advice i had for them to
the advice that you get from like
the worst baseball coach in little
league who like watches you hit a home
run
and just like do that again do that
again like do that again that
is useless in baseball but i think i i
think
you know legislating is actually a very
complicated thing but
given the limitations that democrats
have they have 50 votes everyone needs
to be on board so everyone's potentially
a king maker
anyone could spoil this thing so
basically everyone has to agree not to
do that
once you get that kind of consensus that
we have to just move
then i think it's possible and it's not
a model of legislating that i think
you'll see repeated a lot in history if
they do it um
you know legislation tends to the
acrimonious but um
uh but i think it's you know it is
possible because what you say like the
the rescue plan was a huge win
uh they feel good about it so why not
repeat the process
i find myself cautiously optimistic
somehow because
we do we need to do a lot more uh and
the biden administration frankly rests
on being able to get
a significant infrastructure bill passed
uh
when i spoke to joe not that long ago he
literally said to me we need to rebuild
the country
and this is the the bill to do that he
met literally too it's like we literally
need to rebuild the country
[Music]
all right if you're like me when you
have a bad night's sleep you remember it
like i can remember
three or four maybe my top 10 even like
worst
night sleeps because it just kills you
and like either up
all night or you wake up with massive
backache and i'm proud to say
that i'm a massive supporter of helix
sleep because
they give me great night sleeps i have
the king lux mattress
it's massive it's comfortable it is
perfect
oh i'm a huge huge helix fan so you go
online you take a two-minute quiz
you match a mattress with your body type
with your hot sleeper you're like a firm
mattress like soft mattress doesn't
matter you figure out what your custom
preferences are you get matching the
mattress they ship it to you in a box
it pops out beautifully no hassle super
easy it was an overall mattress top pick
2020 by gq and wired magazine
so here's the deal go to helixsleep.com
yang and take their two minute sleep
quiz
and they'll match you to a custom
mattress that'll give you the best sleep
of your life for
real helix is offering right now up to
200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows
for our listeners at helixsleep.com
yanks that's helix h-e-l-i-x sleep.com
yang for up to 200 off and two free
pillows
[Music]
so when you were describing this process
just now brian you were centering on the
50 senators which i think i naturally do
too
does that mean that you think that
getting a really significant
wide-ranging bill
through the house on the democratic side
is less of an issue because their
majority there is not massive
either i think they can lose maybe five
or six votes
uh and and pass something without any
republicans
um your description was about the 50
senators is is that a greater issue to
pass something really significant
nancy pelosi is a a lion of the house
for
this reason she's really really really
good at passing
big bills particularly ones that are
that
are complex but needed for the the party
to accomplish its goals right like
what she did in 2009 with the affordable
care act even
like the um was it the waxman marquis
climate change bill that ultimately
didn't even pass in the
in the senate you know she had a much
bigger majority to work with then but
those were
uh those are much harder issues than
spending money on things people
understand need to be financed right um
elder care new roads and bridges et
cetera like this is all popular easy
stuff you're not
you're not like remaking the energy
market you're not remaking the health
care market
so um i i think that a the fact that she
has wiggle room at all will help um and
b
uh the um you know her skill
in in wrangling together 218 votes for
for big bills will just make that more
doable with with 50 it's
uh in in the senate it's just tougher
you know there's
when the margin for error is literally
zero it changes a lot of dynamics
it also i think in some ways helps
because
you know everyone has an incentive to
play along because they don't want to be
the one that causes the whole thing to
fall apart so
um i think that will help
both pelosi and schumer get something
passed um
but my suspicion is that if this is
going to work out you're not going to
see the house
pass something wildly different than
what biden proposed
it'll be like the rescue plan it'll have
to go in a sort of similar fashion where
the house
passes something very in line with what
he proposed
the senate passes something very similar
to that
and then the house takes what the senate
passes i think that
there's not a whole lot of wiggle room
to get creative with this and do you
know
two wildly different bills a conference
committee
um because you know any big changes
spoil the coalition
uh in one chamber or the other so you
the they have to move
uh on very very similar tracks
wow pressure's on chuck schumer um when
i saw him today he didn't seem like
he was under any stress at all
i mean it is fascinating though um like
the the
magnitude of the opportunity i mean that
like a lot of things that people have
wanted for years are on the table
it's kind of amazing here's the other
thing though is is
when you have a 50-vote uh
senate majority i don't want to be like
grim or whatever but like
elsie hastings passed away this past
week
that brought the house majority from i
think 222 to 221 or something like that
um but if it had been at a 218 217
house suddenly it would be a 217 217
house or
whatever you see you you see where i'm
going with this is that
chuck schumer can't be certain that he's
going to wake up as majority leader
tomorrow
wow things have things happen in life i
mean
they happened in 2009
well but if you really think
passing this thing is is necessary for
the country
key for the democratic party's viability
for joe biden's legacy
speed is of the issue is of the essence
because
you you just don't know what's going to
happen in the future and so you
time is not really a luxury i agree with
this sentiment i like where you're at
brian you're like full steam ahead
but yeah just stop trying like don't
predict the future don't don't assume
that your 50 votes is going to be with
you from here to the end of the congress
use it while you have it because you you
don't know when you're going to wake up
and it's going to be gone
um and you know i i think that a lot of
people who work in politics
come to think of themselves as being
invincible
and can't see can't imagine the world
carrying on without them and so this is
not natural for them
to think that their own vulnerabilities
as humans might get in the way
of historically important things
happening
um but it it can and i mean it did
uh when barack obama was president right
ted kennedy passed away
there was a special election to fill his
seat and democrats lost that seat
with it they lost their 60-vote majority
and who knows
what world we'd be living in today if
that hadn't happened you are you're a
highly logical man brian i really enjoy
talking to you about this stuff i'm
going to coin a term for you you can
feel free to use it if you like it
political physicist all right i like it
brian boiler is a political physicist
and then you can just because
you just give such logical analyses
uh of each of these issues uh and i love
it
you know i can see why you have such
frankly incredible responsibility
helping shape the
the views of millions um so
the hundred days is starting to actually
wrap up which is crazy
you know i can't i mean thank goodness
like you know thank goodness joe's
president
thank goodness things are going well i
will say that i am
very much enjoying the biden
administration like i'm super it's been
a nice surprise right
a bit of a relief yeah go joe really i
you know and i spent a lot of time with
joe on the trail for whatever reason joe
and i were
booked back to back in probably a dozen
events in iowa and new hampshire which
is interesting because joe's obviously a
headliner and i was generally not the
headliner but for whatever reason i was
next to him a lot
spent a lot of time together backstage
he was always incredible to me
even when frankly there was like zero
uh evident political upside in being
uh really gracious to me you know like
very early on like he was one of
actually the first major candidates to
be genuinely warm and friendly and human
towards me it's one reason why he is who
he is frankly and someone who's he's
president he's just like a
he's a good guy so i always really
enjoyed spending time with joe on the
trail um i think his administration has
been a pleasant surprise for
um a lot of folks and so now that his
hundred days are
almost over are you going to then start
a new podcast about his next hundred
days
and are you going to and like what do
you project for the
the next stage um so i don't know what
we're gonna do
if uh will there be a rubicon season
three
or a rebranding of the show or i don't
even really know what my numbers are so
it's possible they'll be like you're
done podcasting brian
um but uh you know i think
not to spoil what we're working towards
in the finale but like the premise of
the show
is 100 days is just kind of a made-up
benchmark there's nothing special about
that number
there's something true about the idea
that
presidents can sort of make or break
their presidencies early on
um if they come in prepared and do a lot
of big stuff at the gate
it can set the stage for success and if
they don't do that they can fail and you
know
uh the the trump administration was omni
shambles
uh from the get-go but it might have
been a very different situation if they
hadn't thrown out
chris christie's transition playbook
started from
scratch after he won the election you
know if if
if there had been processes in place to
do things
in a considered way his he you know so
not the trump administration no of
course not right
but like i i i don't think that
it's hard to imagine a successful trump
administration but i think that
it became impossible to recover for him
that you know the instant they made that
call like you can't
you can't uh undo that um
and so the idea
with the show is is biden going to not
cement his legacy although he might who
knows but uh is he going to
create a foundation um that can carry
him to
the end of a successful presidency in
four or eight years and i think that
um what what you're saying is is yes
there's one thing unique about this
situation which is like
barack obama had a successful 100 days
too
in some respects um but
at the end of those hundred days i don't
think it was necessarily clear what had
to happen
for the next several thousand days uh to
cement his legacy like he wanted to pass
the health care bill and he did um but
that was really a matter of like
wrangling votes and
was it going to take a few months or the
better part of a year as
it turned out to take with with biden i
think that what
what's unique is that while he's laid
this foundation
it can all kind of peter out because he
doesn't have those huge majorities
and if he's going to continue
implementing his agenda
um he's going to need to convince
democrats to
govern and and change the senate rules
if that's required so what you just said
was
essentially like hey we should get rid
of the filibuster in the senate which by
the way i totally agree with it's a
made-up rule
they adopted themselves yeah they can
unadopt it
you know there's no reason not to so i
just want to make clear that it sounds
like you're in the same camp
oh yeah i mean i i have been since
when i was like a a freshman journalist
like a like
super green i think democrats were
having a fight with republicans over
george w bush's judicial nominees
and my inclination was to be like you
know we don't want those crazy people on
the bench
but then i learned what what they were
what what that meant in in practice was
that democrats were just kind of
arbitrarily saying that you need 60
votes to pass stuff
and it made no sense to me and i'm like
why why is this a rule we're not gonna
like that
if you know after eight years of george
w bush there's a lot
to clean up and and republicans can just
say nah that that requires 60 votes
so it's been a it's been a 16 year
process of me trying to shake people
you were ahead of the curve on this
brian you were anti-filibuster before it
was cool
it's also it's also good to you know
because there's a lot of hypocrisy
around
political process right in general uh
and
it it buys you i think a little bit of
credibility when under george w bush you
were saying the filibuster's a bad idea
well um like he's like you're not you're
not just saying it you're not because
the one side
is oh my god you're like look this
didn't make sense no matter who was in
power
which is true it never did make sense
the jobs plan could pass
theoretically without
without changing the filibuster rules
because of how the budget process works
but you know all around the country and
state legislatures that don't have
filibusters
republicans are passing bills to
disenfranchise people
and the only cure for that is for
federal legislators to pass legislation
to protect their rights
please and and and you cannot put a bill
reestablishing the voting rights act or
creating statehood for
people like me if the filibuster's in
place it just it will not happen
both biden but also his allies in
congress need to ask themselves
do we want this to be the high water
mark and then for the water
level to fall to a very low level
it'll be a real quiet place around
congress
uh there will have been this crush of
activity at the outset of his
administration and then
for the next three years and nine months
it's gonna be not much um
i i that is so clear to me that that
could happen
um that it's hard to to say you know yes
like his first hundred days have been a
success they've laid a great foundation
for future success
but there is a thing that's unaddressed
that could spoil it all and we don't
know how that story's gonna end
so maybe that's season three of rubicon
right there maybe
no the the powerful message i got from
you just then brian which i completely
agree with
and you could apply it to a lot of
things in your life is keep
going keep going democrats you've got a
few
successes on your belt really one big
one but it's cool it was so big we'll
count it as several
just keep going just like keep trying to
get some more wins under your belt
uh so brian if someone enjoyed this
conversation which i did immensely and
they want to hear more about
your perspective on what's going on
which i find profoundly
uh rational and edifying
how can they best find you and keep up
with you the podcast is rubicon but it
sounds like that might be
the season might be ending uh is it to
follow crooked media you directly
i i will take i will take the personal
follows directly i
i tweet at brian boiler i have a
weekly newsletter called big tent
i also edit our nightly newsletter which
is called
what a day um i write articles and
publish articles by others
at crooked.com and obviously our our
if you go to crooked.com and click the
podcast button
our company now has i don't know a dozen
or something
uh uh podcasts obviously the flagship is
pod save america but
there's so many good shows on there um i
would encourage people to go
and just pick ones on topics that you
like like
you're not obligated to listen to
everyone i'm not even sure that would be
would be possible but definitely do the
other stuff the
twitter and newsletter stuff and and and
the articles do that first reading is
better than listening
amen have you written a book that i
missed
i haven't i've i have you know i've
started and junked a number of proposals
because
um part of it's um
self-doubt but a lot of it is just that
you know a lot of people write books and
then they they're on the shelves for a
couple months
maybe they get a few good reviews they
sell a few thousand copies but then
they're
kind of forgotten because they're about
a specific thing at a specific moment in
time
uh and it's rare for somebody who's a
political journalist to write a book
that's
that stands the test of time um and
i would feel frustrated by spending a
year or two on a book that was relevant
for a couple months so i've been trying
to
hone in on any a couple of ideas but any
idea that i think
is sort of bigger than the news um
because the news comes and goes
um so i i i intend to write a book i
want to have written a book in the same
way i kind of want to have run a
marathon
um i'm just not sure what it'll be about
or when but um
i will keep you posted hey i'll even
like message you
with ideas and maybe you can help me uh
shape them a little bit
well i i let me just say that uh i would
be
among the first in line if you did write
a book brian i think you've got an
incredible
point of view that the country in the
world needs so
count me among those pushing you to say
you know i really
think you you should take some of your
perspective and ideas
and i think you've got a lot a lot to
offer
brian thank you for everything you do
and help keep
us heading in a better direction brother
appreciate the heck out of you and
congrats on the incredible
uh role you have i mean it really is a
like an awesome
organization that reaches i think tens
of millions of people every day so
congrats man
thank you appreciate it thank you so
much brian follow this man
[Music]
you